[Music]
uh Mac did you guys see the message rip
a sent Ethan van scriver yeah I did kind
of see that uh Eric July like sent a
message saying like why aren't you like
uh so he sent to even van Sher Sher he's
our fan the comic guy that's our even
van Sky he's a cool dude uh yeah he um
he was saying I don't know he was
basically implying that like he was
having his back good enough or whatever
really gay so this is the message that I
okay so hold on here it is here it is
here it is here it is this I I actually
have I I don't know who's this is a here
we go Ethan Rules by the way he's a cool
dude he's messaged us he's a fan of the
show he's actually really nice guy we've
working on getting him on but I received
this was a tweet out of nowhere and
tweets from Eric they don't come very
often I don't ask for him I never tweet
him he tweets me so it says I'm going to
be 100 with you and not be public about
this you going out of your way to play
the middle of the road publicly with a
dude referring to veto that has gone out
of his way to work over time to publicly
defame is whack uh it's even weaker that
you lend Credence to their
narrative meaning their
criticism I'm supposed to just go their
criticism was invalid because it was in
bad faith I I'm not doing that he says I
treat you like I do anybody else in this
space that's weird I'm Ethan van skyver
perhaps you should be treating me
differently than everybody else in this
space I'm somebody who's been doing
comics for 30 [__] years he actually
has though I was nominated for an Eisner
you sitting there telling me that I'm
receiving equal treatment to your fans
is
interesting uh and I do not use my
platform to amplify narratives that go
against others I'm cool with everybody I
do maybe now's a good time to get them
on show streams with NOS not to bring up
gripes with people I'm cool with is I
will not give it the time of day he says
I'm going to start reciprocating on that
I don't is that mean is that a threat
what you're talking about it does feel
like a little implied right yeah I don't
know what you're talking
about to me I hear this he goes if you
want to chat about it you're free to
call so we did we got on the
phone to me I received this as
stop criticizing me in public uh or I'm
going
to uh basically I'm going to unleash
influencers who want to go at you I'm
gonna tell them they can go ahead and go
at you he really is acting like a mob
boss huh yeah Eric Eric thinks he's a
mob boss huh he fancies himself a a
brilliant writer a tough guy uh and also
a legal expert he wears a lot of hats
they're all dun caps dun caps of various
different colors but he wears a lot of
hats none of the bills are bent
[Laughter]
though [__] buffoon yeah he really is
a he's dude Eric Eric July destroyed his
entire business Ethan has forgotten more
about comics than Eric will ever know
like it really [__] insane to me
right this guy worked on mainstream [__]
for years he made good Comics Green
Lantern I remember read his Green
Lantern was really good like yeah what
are you talking about it was just a
threat it was a a a nicely carefully
worded threat it was Green Lantern right
I'm pretty sure because that's what it
was his
yeah uh so uh I sat on this I called him
I talked to him I said this is a threat
Eric you're threatening me he goes
threaten I go you know where I'm from
I'm not stupid this is a threat you're
basically telling me that if I don't
shut my mouth uh you're going to allow
your friends who are in high places who
are influencers on YouTube by the way we
give a [__] about them by let's be clear
about them we don't care about these
[__] so to attack me that's what
you're saying here and he was
like I said Eric I I I got to tell you I
got to be honest with you about all this
stuff we got to be able to talk about
this stuff you and I uh you know I mean
I I give you I give you advice and you
just you know basically don't listen you
may it's a mistake not to listen I'm
giving you decent advice it's leading
you down a path where it's making your
life more and more
difficult and you know uh he said you
know he said you know what Ethan he said
uh you think you're more important to
Indie comics than you actually
are the guy who started Comics gate what
did he really say that to him yeah to
the guy who started comic skate he
choked on the last word and kind of
pulled it
back is he [__] [__] a whole
[__] shitload of resentment
underneath the surface of
this uh that I've just kind of tapped
into Eric seems like a nervous
wreck good he's getting sued by Isam and
then that tweet came out that he did
know about the Christian Ministry you
saw that then he said I never heard
about it but there was a tweet where he
did know about it I'll snag it so I
talked to him and I said I understand
why me disagreeing with you publicly uh
might cause you
stress and I will try not to do that but
don't threaten me like this ever again
and he smiled and went okay we're
cool well and all he had to do was say
all Eric had to do was say nothing Eric
is burning his [__] business to the
ground and I don't
understand so I sat with this for since
well that was August when he got the
message August 11th until now and I
thought about what a coward I am uh for
not immediate exposing this for not
immediately sharing this gets props gets
props now though for at least going like
I was kind calling yourself out always
almost Pro me you're like I was wrong I
should have [__] done something
earlier I should have done it right
away not cuz I'm mad at Eric or anything
like this but this isn't cool like is he
doing this to other people yes yes yes
yes he's getting accounts of course of
course he's Steve PMI Crossing names off
his
list by the way everybody just keeps
talking about his outfit he's a [__]
he's a lifelong Comic Book Guy yeah like
what do you expect him to dress like
[__] sea Connor's 007 yeah like what
an a Phillies fan yeah I mean what
because everybody seems to be afraid to
like read the comic and criticize it or
offer genuine criticism everybody seems
afraid they're afraid comic gate is you
know that's not what Comics Gate's
supposed to be it's like people are
supposed to be making comics and having
it's like this wasn't so good yeah
apparently he went on Rada show too
after this oh okay um I I look I like
him but it's oh yeah you could tell one
of the donations no comment from
arada